I'll bet beg I don't think we're going
to have a thousand dollars all right
shake hands hey guys I'm off the grid
for August but my girl Roseanne is back
and laying it out like nobody else
in Camp I don't think we're gonna have
no electricity 24. I'll bet how much 100
bucks how much you got not as much as
you
I'll bet beg I don't think we're going
to have a thousand dollars all right
shake hands I hate shaking hand go like
this it's worth it oh that was good a
thousand dollars so if we have an
election 2024 you're gonna give me a
thousand dollars uh-huh okay Jake does
she have it yeah does she have you don't
have like a Britney Spears relationship
with her right she has she has control
of her money not a thousand bucks but
okay you're gonna have to pay me a
thousand one we do not have money I
would be delighted well I'll buy you a
nice dinner on top of that why do you
think there won't be an election because
I think the corruption is just beginning
to uh come out and I think it's going to
Avalanche the corruption of the Biden
Administration and the money they took
versus going to be about Ukraine and
Russia then it's going to go into China
then it's going to go into the OJ and
it's going to be like a big old I have
no prompt an election huh that would
prompt an election no because I think
that uh it's going to get so bad in the
streets too that I think the military is
going to step in I mean Michael we've
talked about the uh many people have
come on the show said this is like the
one time they actually are are not
convinced there will be an election that
is not to say we hear that every four
years but no no no no no come on yes we
do not like now I remember very vividly
in newsmax.com in 2000 they were arguing
that Clinton is not going to leave the
White House and they argued that in
2016. yes but that's not every single
time this is the Trump the culture War
period do you want to in this action too
I'll bet a thousand dollars with you too
I didn't say there wasn't gonna be
election I'm saying we've had people on
the show where we've discussed what is
the potentiality what is the percentage
rate of there not being an election and
it's not zero we had that's it's not
zero that's fair we had an election
during the Civil War we had an election
during World War II so I'm my the best
predictor of future behavior is history
so if there was precedent for cancer
elections I'd be more receptive to this
argument I don't and here's the thing
they don't need to cancel it exactly
that's the point it's much better for
them to have a perception that we this
is we have a when Trudeau got reelected
hold on let me finish my points in one
second when Trudeau just got reelected
with the exact same number of seats as
previously he said I have a mandate so
they will absolutely have the election
whatever happens they'll say we have a
man they do with whatever we need to
clarify this
information comes out we need approves
uh things that certain people don't
think are ever going to be proven okay
we need to clarify this bet
what do you mean by election
uh
I I mean um
a a presidential election yeah people go
in and vote okay so in 1876 people went
into vote Yes and then the president was
determined by a committee no there were
two sets of electors in Florida I just
read a book about that and they and they
had elections and the election didn't
matter it did matter it just it was
question of which of the votes are the
ones to count and you know why who
decided which votes to count because
yeah they had a they had a conference
and so and they still had the election
they decided we are going to end
reconstruction and we're we're going to
split this up so that you know that they
don't have another that's a historical
myth I'm telling you I just read a book
about this literally like in the last
six months like so that was why is that
book correct than what I read not
correct because okay I don't know maybe
I'm wrong the point is I just read a
book about this this has been a
historical thing that they cut this deal
behind the scenes it was much more
complicated than that uh that's all I'm
gonna say but I'm not here to argue it's
1876. well with modern day elections I'm
concerned that there's gonna be a dog
and pony show and they're like hey
everybody voted and they're like hey but
we're just gonna go in the back room and
count it and tell you what the answer is
you're like dude show me the votes in
public like there's no for them to
actually have military law it's really
hard to put that over
well it might already be under a
military law and a lot of people don't
know that we are have you seen what your
your average SWAT team looks like they
look just like Special Forces